[Music]
now that the Amazon series The boys has
a massive fan base there will soon be a
new spin-off from the main series the
spin-off gen V is the second of its kind
after the animated series The Boys
diabolical already made its debut as can
be gathered from a post on the official
Twitter Channel a few days ago the
shooting of the spin-off has been
concluded added to it are a few pictures
showing the cast behind the camera
unfortunately no official images from
the upcoming series have been published
by the responsible parties yet however
considering the recent rap of filming
the first promo images can be expected
soon the story of gen V revolves around
the life of the younger generation of
soups at College as we could already
tell from a Twitter video in mid-july
generally genvi is supposed to be much
like the main series which means it
won't cut any Corners when it comes to
Broad humor and brutal violence however
the primary setting is a bot University
dedicated specifically to Zeus as of now
we don't know when exactly gen B will
kick off on Amazon Prime but we will
keep you posted as always
this week there were New pieces of
information about the upcoming Amazon
series Blade Runner 2099 in the meantime
the project which was announced back in
February ran into some difficulties when
it came to making the script many even
feared that the series would not be able
to last beyond the pilot episode as The
Hollywood Reporter now informs the
series has officially been given the
green light and will therefore be
produced as scheduled based on the title
we can already guess that the series is
set 50 years after the 2017 critics
favorite Blade Runner 2049 Vernon
Sanders Amazon's head of global
television confirmed that the company
was excited to introduce Prime video
customers to a continuation to one of
the greatest and most influential
science fiction movies of all time Blade
Runner 2099 is a collaboration between
Amazon Studios and the production
company Alcon entertainment with free
Scott Productions also involved the
latter is owned by director Ridley Scott
who is known to have directed the
original Blade Runner from 1982 and is
now part of the team as a producer there
are no details regarding the plot yet
but we do hope to have the first story
details or news about the cast soon the
streaming release of Blade Runner 2099
is still uncertain as well
at Disney's recent d23 Expo there were
numerous announcements and trailers for
the company's upcoming projects among
them were of course several series and
movies from Phase 5 and 6 of the MCU now
that the final movie of phase 4 Black
Panther 2 wakanda forever will soon be
released one of the indisputable
highlights of the coming years will be
the Avengers the Kang Dynasty although
the fifth part of the Avengers Saga
won't be released until 2025 key
decisions are already being made at an
early stage to guarantee that the final
result will live up to expectations one
of these is the signing of the new
screenwriter Jeff loveness he is better
known as the author of Rick and Morty
yet he is also writing the script for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania that
makes perfect sense since the new Marvel
villain Kang the Conqueror will be
making his first appearance there the
director of Avengers the Kang Dynasty is
destined Daniel [ __ ] whose past work
includes Xiang Chi and the legend of the
10 Rings how exactly Ant-Man and the
wasp quantumania and Avengers the Kang
Dynasty will end up being connected
cannot be said yet at any rate we are
excited about it and look forward to the
theatrical release on May 2nd it 2025
further news is available on Fantastic
Four here too there has been some work
behind the scenes resulting in the
announcement that two scriptwriters have
been hired according to deadline Jeff
Kaplan and Ian Springer are Penning the
script for the MCU film both have been
in the business for a while though they
have not really had any major
breakthroughs in the field of big
Hollywood Blockbusters we are looking
forward to the final outcome Fantastic
Four we'll arrive in theaters on
November 8 2024.
about two weeks ago Disney's well-known
d23 Expo took place at the Anaheim
Convention Center those who have not had
enough of all of the information about
the MCU Pixar and more can now look
forward to the official follow-up from
Disney this week many of the projects
have now either received a release date
for the first time or the previous one
has been postponed in total around a
dozen movies are affected which we would
like to present to you in short five
films have been assigned a release date
in the following order wish on November
22nd 2023 Pixar's Elio on March 1 2024
Disney Snow White on March 22nd 2024
Pixar's Inside Out sequel on June 14
2024 and Mufasa The Lion King on July
5th 2024. some movies have merely had
their release dates adjusted the new
dates include Haunted Mansion on August
11 2023 blade on November 3rd 2023
Captain America New World Order on May
3rd 2024 Thunderbolts on July 26 2024
and Fantastic Four on November 8th and
24. the following year we'll then see
the releases of Avengers the Kang
Dynasty on May 2nd 2025 and Avengers
secret war on November 8th 2025 in close
succession another Marvel movie is also
scheduled to be released after
Thunderbolts on September 6 2024
officially kicking off phase six however
it is not known what the title will be
yet sadly the release date of Star Wars
Rogue Squadron from director Patty
Jenkins which was supposed to be
released in December of 2023 is now
uncertain due to various production
issues the theatrical release has now
been suspended for the time being all in
all there's a lot going on at Disney and
fans can now Mark a few new days in red
on their calendar apart from the absence
of the theatrical release of Star Wars
Rogue Squadron there were not any big
surprises in the announcements
most fans know Hollywood star Keanu
Reeves Above All For The Matrix movies
or in recent years for the very
successful John Wick Trilogy the most
successful at the box office was
Constantine from 2005 a film adaptation
of the well-known hellblazer comics from
DC about John Constantine a magician an
exorcist who usually appears in the
trench coat specially the ambivalence of
the main character and the morally often
questionable Compass make John
Constantine an intriguing protagonist
and the epitome of an anti-hero moreover
the clever tactician did not acquire his
abilities by accident or a mentor rather
he has grown to be who he is through
years of training and a will of iron no
matter what he may say or do it could be
nothing more than a trick that cunningly
manipulates the other person now after a
long time a sequel starring Keanu Reeves
is coming behind the camera director
Francis Lawrence and producer JJ Abrams
are back for a second time the
screenplay is by I Am Legend writer
Akiva goldsman presumably one of the
driving forces behind the belated sequel
was even Keanu Reeves himself since the
58 year old had been contemplating a
return to the role of on Constantine for
some time in the meantime there were
even rumors that a series by JJ Abrams
was in the works but with the
announcement of Constantine 2 and the
involvement of his company Bad Robot
Productions it is considered unlikely
that this is still in the planning stage
fans now hope for a sequel that lives up
to its popular precursor and is similar
in terms of style and the likability of
the characters a release date has not
been fixed yet
this week we received news that Sony has
decided to reschedule some of its
upcoming movie projects for years the
company has been striving to further
establish its own Universe alongside the
big competitors Marvel and DC since Sony
has many great titles in its catalog and
can also still claim the rights to the
Spider-Man film series with Tom Holland
this endeavor is certainly ambitious but
not unrealistic nevertheless there is
one setback to report in the rapidly
expanding SSU recently the responsible
parties announced that two movies will
deviate from their original release
dates one of them is Craven the Hunter
and the other one is Madame Webb the
former should have already been released
in early January 2023 while the
continued lack of promo material already
suggested otherwise therefore the
postponement to October 6 2023 is hardly
surprising similarly Madame web which
originally should have been released on
that 6th of October has now been pushed
back to February 16 2024. Sony has not
given any specific reasons for the
delays of the two SSU films however it
can be assumed that production or
post-production is simply taking more to
time than expected due to the two
changes the new Garfield movie with
Chris Pratt has also been pushed back
and will not be released until May 24
2024 instead Scott Beck's new sci-fi
thriller 65 with lead actor Adam Driver
will be released a bit sooner on March
10 2023.
so much for this week's news if you
still want to learn more we have a
preview of Indiana Jones 5 on our
Channel there you can find out more
about the current status of the upcoming
Adventure film in the meantime we're
collecting the next news see you next
week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]